so then if people are saying you're
stealing the money
that that just isn't true right what up
boys
uh bad hair days we're just rocking the
hat let me just say right off the top
don't forget the drip is going live on
coffeezilla
at 8 30 central time 9 30 eastern time
tonight be there
we're having ryan long on the show you
may know him from this me and brad first
matt i didn't think we'd get along but
it turns out we kind of agree on
everything
your racial identity is the most
important thing everything should be
looked at through the lens of the race
you owe
if you haven't subscribed already go to
our dedicated youtube channel
for the drip because after the live
stream it's going off air
and everything's going to the drip so
subscribe all right with that out of the
way let's talk
because i don't think there's anything
more 2020
than someone accidentally leaving
criminal evidence
in their tick tock can you spot it
everybody always says daddy's money
i'll show you what it is by the end of
the video but make take your guess
there's not even that much in this
picture so please what what is the
criminal evidence
there's criminal evidence in this photo
meet ashley colfage
she's the wife of disabled vet brian
colfaj who incidentally
is right now arrested and behind the
infamous
we build the wall fraud i don't know if
you guys remember that the story has
just broken but a quick rundown for
those of you who don't already know what
this is about
we build the wall was a viral gofundme
campaign that supposedly
was going to build the wall for trump on
private property or whatever and brian
goldfox
a triple amputee war vet was at the
center of it he was the person who set
it all up
and probably the most important part
from this donation campaign was brian's
repeated promises that he would never
take a penny
and the audit committee will ensure that
every penny is accounted for
and every just as we promised every one
of those every dollar from that gofundme
will 100 go only to the construction of
the border wall
it's not possible for the steal the
money we set up a corporation
we have an advisory board by the way i
decide no anytime somebody says it's
impossible for them to commit financial
fraud
so don't worry about it don't you don't
have to be skeptical because it's
impossible
run very very far away uh that's always
a big red flag
we have a audit committee we have a
finance committee and we have
experts that are keeping track of every
penny every single penny i mean he even
tries to say that
they set up a corporation so it's
impossible it's
it's a corporation um i can't touch that
money it's not for me
like brian that's not what setting up a
corporation does in fact a lot of people
set up corporations
to commit financial fraud not to make it
impossible so
two years later it all comes out that
brian of course is just lying he's been
taking money from the fund all along
four people in connection with an effort
to privately fund a wall along our
southern border
were arrested today on federal charges
brian colfaj is the founder of the we
build the wall crowdsourcing campaign
he was arrested thursday morning on
fraud charges it's always weird for
people
like me or like you you know i'm
assuming you're not a sociopath here
uh to see these liars come out because i
don't know for me
like not just i'm not playing this up
for the camera like i think it looks
sincere when he's saying this he seems
to really believe
what he's saying like he's constantly
defending himself in these tweets look
at this
a hundred percent means a hundred
percent board won't see any of that
money
and again a hundred percent of every
penny donated to the gofundme campaign
goes to construction of wall not admin
he even goes as far as to pitch his
other coffee shop business under the
guise of well
we're not making any money from this
like wall thing we're doing so i've got
to take care of my family so go support
my
k-cup business or whatever and it's all
a lie in the doj release that was
released yesterday
not only was cole fodge taking a salary
they were plotting to hide it he was
taking a hundred thousand dollars
lump sum and then he was getting paid
twenty thousand dollars a month
all from a fund that he's not supposedly
not taking a penny from
here's what they said in the doj release
as far as the public
knows no one is getting paid salaries
will never be disclosed and they were
hiring it through a series of shell
corporations
but how did we find out i mean obviously
in these cases you never really know
until you know the investigators
actually say but i think i have an idea
because the problem with paying yourself
is that it becomes
tempting to spend at a time when you're
claiming to be barely above water with
your k-cup business right because he's
saying i'm broke i'm broke i'm doing it
for the people
but he was starting to spend some money
on a boat
a luxury range rover a golf cart jewelry
cosmetic surgery personal tax payments
and credit card debt
and here is where the problem comes in
the double threat because already you
shouldn't be spending money when you say
you're
basically broke but the second problem
is that brian
has a wife and his wife thinks of
herself sort of as a professional model
and she took these expenditures which
were very expensive which should have
been kept
private and maybe they could have laid
low and she then went
and blasted them across social media to
help her
modeling career i'm not kidding here she
is on tick tock washing their golf cart
they bought with the wall money to
rebuild the wall money
here she is again on their luxury boat
the war fighter brian
bot with wall money uh here she is
traumatizing her child of course
here she is in their upgraded pool like
this lady cannot stop flexing
all their donators money it's it's
actually pretty incredible
and all of this brings us back to the
original video because the criminal
evidence in this video if you haven't
guessed already
is the hundred thousand dollar range
rover the coal fossils bought with
donators money
and the justice department claims it in
their case against the coal fodges here
look
they're claiming the range rover now
what's funny
is that you know ashley tried to really
play it up she tries to claim that it's
her money that bought the range rover
everybody always says daddy's money
uh yeah gotta disagree with that one i
think uh it's not daddy or mommy's money
i think it's the donator's money and
look at the end of the day
do i know that it was her tick tock that
got them caught i don't know
nobody knows what exactly led to the
chain of evidence here
but i'd like to think that it's this
lady flaunting and flexing their wealth
over their donator's head
that finally got them to be caught and i
hope that brian colfaj is thinking of
those tick tocks when he's in jail man
it's such a scumbag move especially when
you try to get on your high horse and
say
oh i'm a triple amputee war vet so that
means i can't take your money in fact
it's impossible for me to take your
money
it's it's a corporation um i can't touch
that money it's not for me
you're lying you got caught and um yeah
if you're a donator
to we build the wall if you're wondering
where your money is well just go to
ashley colfax it's instagram or tic tac
you'll find
it's all
[Music]
burn through your there stacks
a mouth full of money
[Music]
comes along